alright guys so we're back and I'm
excited to have both two guys that work
here at Fandango slash Rotten Tomatoes
were all kinda in the same loving family
- monster enthusiasts Dylan Demasi Kevin
Bower thank you so much so I was very
excited that I was basically able to
walk down the hall and ask somebody who
likes monsters and y'all were like yay
me but more importantly like you guys
are a little bit more than that so what
makes you like what do you love most
about monster movies um well I actually
got to my family didn't like scary
horror movies okay so but my dad liked
monsters which is kind of an issue
sometimes so I got into it he showed a
lot of Atomic Age monster movies this
classic 50s a template we weirdly still
use of Soldier finds monster finds an
attractive scientist assistant because
she can't be the main scientist and then
they fight a monster giant insect for
stops like the city Wow yeah and I got
into like watch a lot of those and I
thought they're really fun and I really
just liked their kind of about something
whether it be really blunt about
nucleation or communism there wasn't
anything else out in the 50s and doing
it in kind of a fun kind of creature way
of that that's in the family angle love
it alright so I also came from a pretty
small town and right from the get-go I
kind of felt like an outsider the one
comic book reading nerd before that was
cool somehow got into monsters can't
really say how but what really attracted
me was the idea that they were highly
symbolic everything about most monsters
reflects some core of us that we have
trouble addressing Dracula is fear of
the upper classes fear of sickness
Frankenstein what makes us human what
doesn't invisible men when science goes
too far and proxy to that love of
monsters and finding the human elements
of them was just really becoming
attracted to special effects especially
practical effects the crazier the more
gnarly the more visible and tangible the
better yeah I mean I think Frankenstein
Frankenstein's monster was maybe my
early
memory of saying hey I'm actually
rooting for the creature in this I want
him to succeed I want him to not die I
wanted to find true love and he ended up
doing that with his bride um if we went
to y'all's various residences invited
obviously because we are vampires what
would we see in there that maybe is your
biggest thing that you would need to
save in a fire that that shows everybody
out there hey this is my love of monster
movies on display is there any sort of
piece of memorabilia or something in
your collections even a digital copy of
a film could count a journal of how to
reanimate your own creature wow that's
that's a good question certainly have a
few things I mean my DVD collection I
think is pretty much monsters at this
point Wow
to the point where I'm rocking a creep
show thing yeah I got a whole collection
of German imported special features for
the extra how they made something
actually my favorite we can debate
whether it's a monster is I actually
have there's a nice seventies movie
called this stuff okay my Larry Cohen
and it's about like this organic blob
type thing that people discover and then
start eating and they think it's like an
ice cream thing and then it takes people
over and becomes like a blob monster see
that's why I thought dippin dots at the
mall was when they said was I screaming
the future in my wait whose future we
die and I have a little replica ice
cream canister of that stuff I like that
a lot deep hole and has an edible
quality La Crosse I like mashups let's
be honest all right you know
everything's on the cloud now a day so I
would have to worry about my DVD
collection but memorabilia it's not the
monster movie but man Davy Jones from
Pirates of the Caribbean - yeah he's
treated like Phantom of the Opera he is
the same forlorn monstrous lover thing
going on and I have a todd mcfarlane
action figure of him that's like a
really high quality sculpt and the crazy
thing is if you watch the original
Phantom of the out for silent movie the
theme song is the same song used in
Pirates of the Caribbean - that he plays
on the organ
Wow definitely no fan of the Opera but I
did not make that like audible
connection when I watched Pirates of
Caribbean 2 maybe because I tried to
sleep that memory maybe it's a little
bit maligned cuz I definitely have
phantom I could do that what any day of
the week so todd mcfarlane I'm glad you
brought that one up real quick what are
you thinking for the spawn movie because
him directing it has me excited but also
scared about the same and hasn't been
the first time we've seen the comic book
artist slash writer do a movie the
spirit was a rough movie but since city
before it was great it was great I think
the idea of making something more like
Sam and twitch where two detectives kind
of stumble on something they really
shouldn't it's a good idea it could be
to bring back the character but spawn is
such this is such a big sprawling
mythology I really don't know if that's
what audiences would want from a spot
movie it's it's a TV show I just always
felt like it's better for the TV show I
always felt the TV show was better than
the movie I just always feel like that
HBO series this is solid yeah absolutely
amazing yeah and the look of just the
look of Hell and and and how you could
portray that on the big screen or on
television I mean this is gonna be a
feature film that it's apparently pretty
low budget and they want to make that by
design so low budget indicates you're
probably gonna be using a lot of
practical effects when it comes not just
to spawn but also maybe the way somebody
like the violator is is gonna look and
and that's something I want to ask you
guys too is that I think most kids have
their their conduit into the world of
monster movies and practical effects by
dressing up as Halloween characters I
had a number of different Halloween
costumes that are back to movie monsters
I was Teen Wolf one year thanks to my
awesome mom you guys have any great
stories about dressing up one year as a
classic monster that you love
I actually did one year was although the
custom wasn't labeled as such but it was
basically a facehugger like a like a
pilot they'd been attacked by a face
hugger I think I was walking around and
at my school you had to do tours of the
classroom in your costume
I don't know why there's any weird to
force kids to do - yeah well not cool to
children I walked around of that and I
was like maybe fifth grade and no one
had any clue what they were looking at
we're just like wow that's a really
weird mask torturous I'm gonna lie to
you by the way I would never dress up
I'm a big fan of dressing up I love
getting in costume it's always been my
thing but if I was at your school I
would like completely run away from that
idea of it just because that to me is
like a child's nightmare like let's go
into a room full of classmates that you
don't know probably don't like you and
have them point and stare at what you
have on line yeah and then like you
think about the mask I'm like the masks
always looked cool like in school were
for the first two trick-or-treating
houses then that third one you realize
how hot it's gonna be for the rest of
the night you think about the actors and
actresses that are in these kind of
costumes like day in and day out your
best Halloween look best Halloween luck
was probably my first time contracting
at Fandango I came as Ghost Rider I had
a mask I got my hair really long painted
it red covered in chains and tried
sipping coffee through the mask didn't
quite work out so well we also had a
parade in front of all of the employees
here you know it's again it's you can't
hear cause like this place is like full
of attention-seeking behavior like it's
a bit it's like everyone loves movies
and wants to tell people about it so
like I blame you at this point children
that's their thing you chose that like
we did it on purpose but this is a big -
it's like in our conversation - I was we
were talking before we got shot I like I
tried to keep it in an area where a lot
of people who are not you know maybe
monster movie people could could have an
entry in you know we got Godzilla we got
Guillermo we got you know things like
that the meg but there's always those
deep holes and like things that maybe
people don't agree or monster movies
like for example my favorite monster
movie is technically also a musical
which is Little Shop of Horrors
heck yeah and Audrey - is the greatest
monster ever
how Seymour didn't guess you know it's
gonna eat people that's beyond me like
that's the funniest part of that movie
it's like by the end when if you ever
watch both the Roger Corman and the
original version of the movie like
Audrey - when she goes on a rampage
throughout New York they made the happy
nice you know Hollywood ending for what
made it to theaters but you know the
plant wins and it's always just funny to
me like when you see that ending it's
like how did anybody know that that was
not gonna happen like you have the like
spoiler warning
here as soon as it's like oh I like
blood it's gonna eat people but I love
that movie
great music great songs what are you
guys like deep hole monsters that you
would be like more people need to be
about this monster okay
so many I kept your for a long time it's
okay I'm gonna hold you this three like
I'm gonna hold you three but I'll let
you have that moment okay I would do a
my favorites a corpsman produced movie
called humanoids from the deep okay I do
know humanoids which is if you thought
shape of water would have been better if
he killed her you would like humanoids
from the deep yeah after that it would
be I really liked the gate okay the
gates classic it's nostalgic like now we
have kids like getting caught up in like
monsters and stuff but the gate is kids
play a record backwards and it actually
has Santana things on it and the Satan's
little minions which are stop-motion
come up and terrorize these kids in a
house awesome I tell you kids don't play
that rock and roll music I agree with
Lithgow and Footloose so that was very
good deep holes huh and then I really
like it's alive oh yeah and the end of
the spoiler are coming I love the end of
that movie where they're like like they
think they just got this baby they got
finally alright let's go it's Miller
time and then they get a colors like
there's another girl just like in
Seattle and they're like oh boy here we
go
spoiler alert also kind of what they did
with the Meg I don't know if you guys
are planning on watching it but it
definitely had a moment of like oh we
think we got it there's like 38
different moments in the Meg Giry like
that was done better in this other movie
one of which is being it's alive yeah I
will say this too I'm glad you brought
up Corman because I feel like we didn't
give him his due because I feel like
Corman is definitely a monster you know
guy but he did so many other things like
he kind of just created it's almost like
if he wanted to do like the toxic
avenger Troma like like they did that
but they did so many other things too
it's like yes I guess key call toxic
avenger monster oh yeah by the way the
first time I saw that movie was the most
hilarious awesome thing I've ever seen
and the thing that cracked me up the
most and I don't know if anybody else
bumped on it was his voice the first
time he spoke with that like hi Susan I
love you like I died I could not stop
laughing at that I rewound it like four
times to make sure I wasn't like under
the influence of I don't know what I was
just like how is this the thing whatever
I watched that movie for the first time
in a college dorm room you can probably
guess the state in which I watched it
but his voice and I've since watched it
I still crack up every single time and
the fact that she had sex with him
because just the logistics and
sanitation of that just bothers me so
much yeah again that's one charming
fella oh I don't care she's blind
this doesn't work it doesn't work it's
the two to whatever uh you know I'm
really excited to see overlord when that
comes out we don't get enough World War
two horror movies it's been a handful
the what was it the rig the raft
something but my all-time favorite is
puppet master 3 one of the many
miniature murderer series produced by
Charles Bend at full moon entertainment
there's this Jewish puppeteer and he has
living puppets
when the Nazis kill his wife and destroy
his puppet studio he decides to get
revenge on some SS officers you have a
six-armed cowboy with a gun in each arm
you have a guy with a hook for a hand
and a blade for an other hand you have a
little pin headed guy with gigantic
hands it's ridiculous but it's insanely
good yeah see my my next question can
also be labeled as Mike my answer for
both the deep pool and the scariest
monster in my opinion is and it's funny
how we sometimes we bend the line of
what an actual we consider an actual
monster but I think this falls under
that category is Zelda from Pet Sematary
because it's just this scary backstory
that this the the wife has where she's
remembering having to go down stay and
take care of Zelda and twist your spine
all that stuff it just the effects that
they used it's all practical stuff like
makeup trim but it's just so horrifying
so I'm taking Zelda for my number one if
we're doing a fantasy team of mobs
I'm trapped in Zelda over Dracula
Creature from the Black Lagoon all of
them if I can ask each one of you fellas
and Jacqueline as well
what is the scariest movie monster of
all time bar none
drop the mic I'm gonna let I'm gonna let
the experts start with this one because
this is the other thing too is I'm kind
of on your dad's thing I like movies and
but I up until like maybe age 25 I
avoided horror movies because I was a
scaredy cat and then my love of film was
like all these filmmakers who I love her
like but I started in Horrors like god I
gotta get some balls and so I'm late on
some of the scarier ones so I get to
take me a minute to think of ones that
scared me
it was weird for me watching them as a
kid because I had the same experience
that you did in college when I first saw
the Exorcist I saw this this this girl
puking her guts out and saying a lot of
bad words and me and my brother my
sister I thought it was hilarious it's
like man she's really given it to her
parents huh man I want to be it was like
watching problem child or something and
then that was in like second grade that
somehow I got to see that movie then I
went back and watched it again at my
buddy's house when we were having a
sleepover in fifth grade and that movie
wrecked me and the only thing I can
compare it to is the first time I saw
Zelda and Pet Sematary cuz I saw that
movie in the theater on the big screen
which will change your perception of how
scary a movie monster is so of course
sure you guys are the experts scariest
one you're not allowed to take any
monsters you see on cereal boxes
Cap'n Crunch though you know like the
thing with movies is every time you see
something it might have an immediate
reaction but you can disavow it pretty
quickly I mean you get over alien you
get over the thing jump scares a jump
scare but something that really gets
under your skin that you have to live
with and can't disavow that's powerful I
think for me it's the creature from it
follows it looks like whatever messes
you up the most
it never stops coming it's directly tied
to something that should be a freeing
growing-up act but really all it does is
remind you of your own mortality at the
end of the day you can run but it will
always be there and when you leave the
theater and process that I mean that's
death no matter how many
I mean how many medicines you take no
matter what exercise you do someday it
will catch you wait damn glass of
whiskey does the fireplace is scary too
for now just think about your like what
am I doing with my life is almost over
sitting here [ __ ] about monster
movies anyway I had that feeling of when
I walked out of the theater when I saw
after I saw it it follows it's it's cool
when a movie can do that to you where
I'm walking to my car and I'm thinking
about what's behind me yeah I see
everybody's like it's kind of walking to
their car too and I'm like wait which
one of you is it I'm not gonna lie to
you to that film as great as it was I
kind of hate it now because it prompted
a 24 to give is it David Mitchell what
does the name how do you say it he's got
three first names something
Mitchell something came the three first
name director of it follows they gave
him a bunch of money to do under the
Silver Lake and that is the worst movie
I've ever seen put to celluloid and is
awful sorry to spoil you but I they move
that movie back six months for a reason
well always have the creeping death yeah
oh yeah well always have the creeping
death movie so yeah yeah but this is a
thing that movie was so good that you'd
be like just make movies dude here's
five million go make a movie and he did
and it was that Wow
see and then I'm over here being like
walk out of it follows that's what it
looks like a monster no not feeling it
not feeling just just a lazy looking
okay I'm not feeling it he didn't like
the monster as much but there you go I
needed I need something that's you know
I'm gonna remember yeah how am i
scariest monster though is I think the
monsters that like when I really like
the raft and it kind of leans to the
blob something that has no opinion or
thought or personality it seems like
it's just killing you because that's
what it does mmm-hmm like there's a
horrific moment in the raft of either
we've seen it in Creepshow to where
they're being chased by this oil slick
looking thing in the water and they're
stuck on this little would like raft and
one of them falls asleep on the raft
she wakes up and it's already taken
ahold of her and the other guys don't
know what
do they just back up and just watch this
poor thing like pull this girl to this
raft but like the monster and it's just
you know it's chillin on a lake it's
doing this thing that seems way more
horrifying to me yeah I think for me so
this is what's really weird because I
don't know if they call the monster
movies but it's definitely the ones
where the monster isn't the monster that
you see but it's the monster that you
see that's effects so like to give you a
perfect example of any tale of the Body
Snatcher type movies freak me the flip
out because it's not so much that the
thing is scary it's that you don't know
who the thing is so anytime you can't
tell yes exactly like that is scary
that is a way cuz every time it's a
monster it's a physical being a physical
thing I will find a way to either make
it ridiculous so that I can enjoy it or
find a way for it not to be scary to me
so it's the unseen thing the unseen
element in the which scared the crap out
of me the unseen elements and like
something like the Miss Steven or like I
said a tail the Body Snatcher so
whatever basically what I'm saying is
that I can scare myself way better than
any of these filmmakers movies though
and that that's something I learned upon
my second fifth-grade viewing of the
Exorcist is that as scary as the movie
monsters are I can put that in a place
in my head where I can come to
appreciate and enjoy them in a way
that's not gonna give me nightmares it's
a psychology behind the the monsters
because like when I was a kid I was
trying to go to sleep and I was scared I
would just imagine that these monsters
were a human being so it'd just be like
Freddy Krueger and Jason are having a
beer at a party and who and then Regan
comes up and then Zelda comes I'd never
thought about Zelda I kept her that she
was not invited to the party but you can
do that but then when you put the
psychology behind them and that's what
the Great's of all time wait whether
it's a filmmaker or somebody who's good
at doing practical or visual effects
they can make you not only scared of
this initial image but it's what comes
with that image that's the most
horrifying thing about scary movies do I
I'd completely agree about that one too
also like you talk about the artistry
behind these two like the thing that I
think is I can appreciate to all of
these every time I look at it the first
thing I think is how did they do that I
think you know when I see how arrays
used to scare me a ton and then after a
while I was just like so how did they
get the symmetry on the pins like that's
cool
and then you know you look at a movie
like the crimson peak is a perfect
example cuz that was a complete marriage
of CGI and you know Doug Jones like
actually crawling through the floor to
make those to make that those ghosts so
for me I'm always like the artistry and
the ones that are most memorable so I
think if I was gonna say my favorite one
of the most memorable it's definitely
not a monster movie but it's got
monsters in it remember the cell yeah
from yeah pretty much every visual in
that movie that was either you know
monster like or scary I just loved I
just wanted to just draw and create and
just live in this like very cool world
that they created in that in the cell
granite it's totally twisted terrifying
movie but I just love the way that it
looked I was like just paint walls like
that it's beautiful
but I that was like a memorable visual
for me you know it's sort of like the
first time you see gear and we'll do the
eyes thing and Pan's Labyrinth or the
golden army like type stuff so what's a
memorable visual monster moment for you
the moment where they split the live
horse organs are still going yeah this
sounds like like the the adult version
like kids go to Willy Wonka's factory
for chocolate and it's like what if you
become an adult and you go to a factory
for just hypnotic nightmarish visions
yeah that's what the sell was yeah so
you don't want that golden ticket I like
a good visual moment yeah like just like
either a monster moment or just like
where they created something we're like
this is like what fan art was made for
you know like I just like the way this
looked something you want to get some
concept art Ford frame
oh well it's it's all it would be also
on my favorite monsters were normally
zombies we like to keep them in their
own category they stay where they are
but occasionally they get to go beyond
that in the Odle 80's punk rock film
Return of the Living Dead oh yeah
there's a main hero zombie which is
called tar man he's like a skeletal
slimy thing which is almost unlike any
other zombie you've ever seen and like
the first time is introduction it's just
this extreme close-up oven bursting out
of this Walker in yelling brains for the
first time in any zombie movie and he's
just
they have like a specific kind of
gymnast acrobatic let's move
in ways that humans shouldn't move and
he just looks so cool you just want like
statues of him you just want the whole
movie to be about him even when he's
chasing after your heroes I've always
kind of loved him look at this now find
that Stephen Sommers gets a lot of
credit for making the mummies movies but
everyone seems to have forgotten deeper
rising it's a fantastic little comedy
horror action movie thing embrace for
some reason but it's Monster is this
strange sea creature that's made of
mouths on tentacles and has a weird
color flower shaped body with teeth it's
it looks simultaneously amazing and just
kind of goofy but his gore effects are
fantastic in this movie whenever these
creatures eat someone they're like half
liquefied as they go through people you
see these piles of just disembodied
corpses half regurgitate it whatever and
it's so McCobb and visceral in that
moment it's like a red painting yeah the
movie moments is it's such a great you
know kind of like all encapsulating the
question because that's why we go to
these movies you know yes we want that
experience we want something to that
that haunts us a little bit afterwards
but it's that one moment when you see
something that you were not expecting
that the filmmaker genuinely surprises
you with so there's one sit that I was
like bracing myself for that still wowed
me like watching Samara crawl out of the
well in the ring and and with the
acrobatics that I could physically go
into that crawl um I think a lot about
the Evil Dead movies what Sam Raimi is
able to just bring when you talk about
fan art just like this explosion of
stuff and so in that vein my answer is
gonna be in cabin in the woods where the
elevator sequence where it's every
childhood nightmare you ever had coming
out of these elevator doors at the same
time it's just so bonkers and a little
funny but also the effects are good
enough to where you buy it and it's just
it's it's such a celebration of
everything that we love about horror so
that's that's the first image that
that's the one that I always think about
if you ask
me for one classic movie monster kind of
moment that's a Gary is a great one as
amazing this is honestly I feel so
informed and scared and I have some new
homework I just had such a blast talking
about monster movies today this is great
and again the fact that I got to walk
what maybe 20 steps to get this yay
office Destin asking to seem like hey
what do you feel like the monster movies
now let's go no I mean but hey look if
this is show we're stats meat cinema and
you guys definitely brought the stats
and the cinema thank you guys so much
for joining us today
like anything oh I'm glad to have you
anything you want to plug before you get
out of here yeah like anyway we want to
follow people folks to follow you online
not like an it follows just actually
just be supportive yes
no just want to thank you guys and keep
us in mind whenever you were thinking of
monsters in horror please do we have
Halloween not too far away
might you care anything you want a plug
no I'm pretty boring just a guy in the
Internet
okay um I do some blogs or Fandango but
nothing really special all right mr.
mark all right I'll take the bait
Jacqueline you can catch me Dragon Con
in Atlanta the last it's either the last
day of August first days of time
whatever that Friday is gonna be doing
some stand-up shows maybe relapse
theater maybe laughing skull maybe both
so you can follow me at Mark Ellis live
in the supportive way not the it follows
way again Jacqueline you can find me
anywhere at that Jacqueline so excited
for our next episode it's gonna be two
of our faves my faves I think Mark's
faves Keanu Reeves and Winona Ryder are
starting a little film called
destination wedding and our next episode
of by the numbers is Keano and Winona
forever we're just gonna take a deep
dive on those two those two guys and the
four movies that they've started
together
yeah Bram Stoker's Dracula definitely
exactly just keeping it all in there
so please tune please tune in next week
for rotten tomatoes by the numbers
[Music]